Record and we are on. So hello, hello. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. It's our Zoom call for the 13th of June. I think it's the 13th of June.
Wednesday and it's just a beautiful day here in Minnesota. Today we're going to talk about several things, Bailey on IGF1.
IGF1 is insulin growth factor one. It is one of the growth factors or growth stimulators in our body that helps us heal.
So let's jump right into this because I talk about IGF1 a lot, but I've never really defined it what it is.
IGF1 is produced through growth hormone from the pituitary gland.
The pituitary gland, it goes into the liver. It's converted to IGF1. It is body IGF products, but IGF1 is the majority that is studied.
It helps with development of growth and of bone. It helps with bone protection, development of growth and protection of the brain and of the heart.
It can be anti-inflammatory. It is a vasodilator, so it can be beneficial for people who have high blood pressure.
And one thought is this is with a lower IGF1 as we age, which typically is true with everyone. Our IGF1 levels decrease as we age.
There's one piece of the blood pressure issue and information about Alzheimer's connected to that too, but it's with high IGF1s.
IGF1 is essential for thymus development and function, making of your red blood cells, immune cell function, your kidney function, and development, making follicles in the ovary and testicular function.
So it has some great functions. Now, there is a lot of use with IGF1, let's see if I put this on the other slide, with cellular regeneration and repair.
So people that have severe autoimmune diseases, they're starting to use in some circles, growth hormones and IGF1 to raise those levels.
Because it can increase muscle, bone and tissue growth. It's used in the anti-aging market, stimulation with growth hormone and IGF1 to make a person feel more youthful, feel more energetic, take away some aches and pains.
So you start thinking, wow, this is a really great thing. Why don't we try to do things that increase IGF1 levels?
Well, if you have cancer or even a smidget of cancer, it increases the growth of cancer cells.
So IGF1 is something that we want to lower when a person is diagnosed with cancer, even if it's in a smoldering phase, in a phase where your IVG is down to six, you want to keep IGF1 levels lower.
So this is just pulled from a study here, I indexed it here, talking about IGF1 levels here and it's risk with cancer.
It's really with, there's probably a thousand studies out there on IGF1 and cancer that also basically say the same thing, increased IGF1 levels are going to increase cancer growth.
Also there's new studies that increase IGF1 levels with Alzheimer's.
IGF1 levels will rise when we eat more food. So when humans are consuming more calories than necessary, it will rise in IGF1 levels.
So that is a huge issue and a huge concern with all mortality issues.
So even though it's kind of an economy, even though IGF1 and growth hormone is used in the anti-aging industry, some doctors that are doing anti-aging and using growth hormones and such because it can make a person feel better, but it actually decreases your life expectancy.
So IGF1 has been showed over and over to decrease the life expectancy of all animals.
So it's not just because of cancer, so it does increase Alzheimer's risk, it increases degeneration ultimately of the brain.
So having high IGF1 levels have a purpose in life in that it helps you heal after an injury and it helps a child grow.
So children have much higher IGF1 levels because that's part of your growth factor system. They're growing an inch a year or whatever state that they're in.
But as adults, we're not growing anymore. And if we're continuing to over consume nutrients and foods that is going to stimulate IGF1 function or if we're taking exogenous IGF1 stimulators to try to feel youth more youthful, we will feel more youthful, but we will age more rapidly.
There's numerous, numerous studies coming out now and I've shared multiple of these with you at different talks that I've given on fast eat, mbike diet, intermittent fasting, and time restricted fasting, whatever we want to call the intermittent, the time restricted are really the same thing.
But the FMD is essential for cancer and we're going to talk about that. So nutrient excess. So when we're consuming too many calories,
and we're starting to gain a little bit of weight around our tummy, the problem is we're rising insulin levels and IGF1 levels and that's that's stimulating more growth, more laid out of fat tissue.
And if we have cancer already, it's going to be increased growth of the cancer. It's going to be an upregulation of the mTOR signaling and we talked about the mTOR pathway multiple times.
IGF1 is just one of those stimulators is going to upregulate or increase the mTOR pathway, which is going to increase growth. All this is the growth pathway.
How your body will take in new nutrients, make more cells, increase growth of cells. So if we have cancer, we do not want to upregulate mTOR, we do not want to upregulate IGF1.
Excess nutrients decreases the NAD, NADH ratio. This is a very important ratio that are going to actually do a presentation on quite soon because there's a lot of talk about using NAD, NADH supplements and it's all about this ratio that we want to maintain.
It blocks the AMP pathway, which also leads to cancer. So all these red things, if you've got excess nutrients, lead to increase aging at a high cancer risk if we already have cancer, increase cancer growth.
Gallery restriction blocks IGF1 signaling blocks mTOR signaling helps balance the NAD to NADH ratio and it increases AMP pathways, which this is an anti cancer anti growth pathway.
So that increases longevity of life and increase a low cancer risk. Here's another picture showing the same thing. What FMD does, that's the fasted mimicking diet, does two normal cells and tumor cells on starvation.
So it really, this is what we really want to look at for tumor cells. On tumor cells, it's going to increase cell death, it's going to decrease growth because it blocks these pathways.
So super important, the FMD intermittent fasting, making sure we're not consuming too many calories.
So this of course gets thrown out the window if we're in a caquexic state with rapid weight loss, it can't seem to keep to hold our weight.
So that's when we have to switch gears a little bit.
Again, this pathway is what we're looking at. We've talked about this in multiple talks, so I won't spend any more time on that.
The next question that came in was, what about rick Simpson oil? Can we use rick Simpson oil? Who's used rick Simpson oil? And where do we get rick Simpson oil?
So remember, we talked about with marijuana. So let's kind of go over this a little bit.
There's three uses of marijuana. There's smokey marijuana. So what would I want to smoke marijuana?
So smokey marijuana can help with, can that help kill cancer? No, smokey marijuana is not going to help kill cancer.
Matter of fact, I'm not a fan of recreational smoking a marijuana because of what it does to the brain. Yes, it does have negative effects on the brain in long term studies.
We used to do a lot of neurofeedback testing and doing brain scans, and you could tell if this person was on marijuana or not.
And we caught some kids that you're smoking marijuana. No, I'm not. Yes, you are. I can see it right here. Okay, they passed up.
So, but what does smokey marijuana do? Well, many times people in later stage cancer have pain, right? Well, smokey marijuana could help take care of pain.
And it has none of the side effects of opiates or other drugs. Smokey marijuana. What else could it do? Well, lots of times people with later stage cancer have difficulty sleeping smoking marijuana could help increase sleep.
It help you sleep better. Could you give you a better night sleep? And if you're not getting sleep, then you're not going to heal.
Healthy marijuana could smokey marijuana can help decrease nausea. Well, that could be a problem with, you know, cancer. So boy, if that can help take care of my nausea that I could eat better.
And they wouldn't be in such rapid weight loss. Well, smokey marijuana could increase appetite. Well, that's part of my problem. I don't have any appetite. It'll feel good. I got nausea. I'm exhausted. I can't sleep.
My sleep is horrible and my pain is wrapped up. Well, smokey marijuana could help with that. So there's a lot of things that smokey marijuana could do. Now, personally, I have not ever smoked marijuana, but some of our patients that have gone to this route, very reluctantly, some of them have been helped tremendously.
So remember that it is simply an herb that grows naturally.
So just like anything else, there's some poisonous things that grow naturally too. Does that mean we're supposed to do so? No, we have to look at the benefits of it and use it wisely.
The second form of marijuana is CBD oil. CBD oil is the type of oil that is typically that used for people with seizures, extremely beneficial for seizures.
And CBD oil can be in a form just like this, though. This is an example of Rick Simpson oil or THC oil, but it can be in a form of this too.
The one CBD high potency CBD oil we have is it a paste like this as well.
So CBD is it a milligram dosage and I've had patients that just spoke to somebody this morning that just started using CBD.
The patient is extremely about to pay it on a lot of opioids and said they tried CBD. It hasn't really helped with the early tried at once, but then I asked about the milligram dosage. She only took about 12 milligrams. So that's not going to do it.
You have to get the milligram dosage up to a high enough point that's going to help take away the pain. CBD can help with pain. There's more and more studies about CBD and cancer itself.
So some cancers respond extremely well to just CBD. CBD is the done psychoactive form of the marijuana. You won't get any side effects of feeling weird and things with CBD.
Even in high doses of CBD, it's extremely well tolerated.
The dose that we have that comes in a form that looks a little bit different like this, but is it a paste type form that we have is 120 milligram a day dosage of CBD. That's a very high dose.
But typically a person would take anywhere between 25 milligrams a day to 150 milligrams a day or even 300 milligrams a day of CBD, depending on what you're trying to do.
And then the THC oil is the rick Simpson's oil. That's called rick Simpson's oil after rick Simpson who really kind of put it out there and you see that how you smash the ball, you boil it down, you dissolve it, you boil it down and then you get it down to a paste that is like a thick molasses is what it is.
So you take it on a basis of there's multiple different dosing charts and I'll show you in just a second.
Different ways to take the rick Simpson oil. Have we had many patients have success with rick Simpson oil. Yes, do I think rick Simpson oil is great. Yes, but I don't think it's any greater than any other kids are killer that we tested people on and use.
With legality reasons, I can't have this in my office to test. This is not legal in every state. This is only legal in states that allow typical recreational use of marijuana.
And there are many states that you could get a card for cannabinoid use that is done by the state. It's done typically through a pharmacy through the state that the state appointed.
I don't know that it's in a, it depends on the state, but it's usually in a capsule form and none of this.
And I don't know the potency of it in it varies from state to state and pharmacy to pharmacy, I'm sure.
How long does a person typically take this person typically takes this for 90 days that is retested.
Rick Simpson's original formula is a 90 day formula, but he does suggest that you might have to do it multiple times. So it is something that you want to look at.
Here's an example of the cannabis oil treatment, starting with three doses daily about half the size of greater rice. Believe me, I've had people that can only start with one dose of a half a size of greater rice.
Because this will make you feel loopy, whereas the CBD oil doesn't really have any side effects the THC oil has quote unquote side effects.
It doesn't necessarily give you the high feeling that smoking marijuana gives you, it gets you right to the feeling really groggy stage, at least this is the experience that I've heard from multiple multiple patients.
And so, dosing it, but this is rick Simpson's dosage, they're getting up to three doses daily of a half a greater rice and a full greater rice.
And then you're up to getting a gram a day, so it does depend on the potency of the formula that you're using, but typically you're getting to a gram of day, gram a day of the CBD oil or the THC oil slash rick Simpson oil.
That can really wipe a person out, I've had people put their whole dosage in a capsule and do it orally, and I've had people put their whole dosage into a homemade coconut oil capsule that they freeze and then they use that coconut oil capsule in a little from a little mold with coconut oil that they do is a suppository before they go to bed.
So there's there's multiple ways to get that in your body, but you do have to ramp up on it, but don't think that, you know, be careful of websites that you have out there that say anything is an end all be all for cancer.
So you have to get this from a state that legally you can get this from and you can get it an order from multiple places if you search online.